and now it's my great pleasure to
introduce professor Maury Cline his new
book is called in rainbows in the crash
of 1929 in this book he offers a vibrant
picture of a world of plungers powerful
bankers corporate Titans millionaire
brokers and buoyantly optimistic stock
market bulls we meet sunshine Charlie
Mitchell head of the National City Bank
powerful financier is Jack Morgan and
Jacob Schiff Wall Street manipulators
such as the legend legendary Jesse
Livermore and the lavish living Billy
Durant founder of General Motors as
Professor Klein falls the careers of
these men he shows us how the financial
house of cards gradually grew taller as
the irrational exuberance of an earlier
age gripped America and convinced us
that the market would continue to rise
forever then in October 1929 came a
perfect storm like convergence of
factors that shook Wall Street to its
foundations we relive Black Thursday
when police line Wall Street brokers
grew hysterical customers bellowed like
lunatics and the ticker tape fell hours
behind this is followed by the even
worse
Bloody Tuesday when an irrational desire
to sell at any price grip the market and
even blue chip stocks plummeted
precariously this compelling history the
crash the first to follow the market
closely for the two years leading up to
this disaster illuminates a major
turning point in our history professor
Morrie Klein is professor of history at
the University of Rhode Island and one
of the most acclaimed historians of
American business at work today he's the
author of many books including the life
and legend of Jay Gould a Pulitzer Prize
finalist unfinished business the
railroad in American life and days of
defiance stunts Sumter's succession in
the coming of the Civil War please join
me in welcoming Morrie Klein
Thank You Joan
I'm very happy to be here and I thought
what I do is give just a little bit of
background and intersperse it with a
little bit of text from the book and
then answer any questions that you might
have there are three questions basically
that still haunt Americans about this
period the first one is what caused the
crash the second one is how and what
effect did the crash have on the coming
of the depression if any and the third
one which seems to be the one that's on
everybody's mind especially these days
is could it happen again
we've now researched read analyze
discussed and dissected these issues for
more than 80 years and the answer to
those three questions are we don't know
we don't know and we're not sure and
there are a lot of good reasons for that
one of the ironies of the modern age is
that we have so many ways of talking
about and hearing about the market that
it's created an even greater illusion of
what we do and don't know than they had
in the 20s so let me try to take you
back to the 20s first because what is
unique about the 1920s is that it really
is the first time the market became a
public institution prior to World War
one almost all of the investing was done
by people who were either wealthy or
financed in the financial community or
in the business community it was not
really a public market as such World War
one changed America in so many ways that
I don't have time to go into but two
ways are especially important for why
the market emerged one was that it
created a whole class of people who had
money that they could actually do
something with I'm not talking about the
wealthy now I'm talking about a growing
middle class who for the first time had
a little something extra in the 1920s
was going to give them plenty of things
to buy thanks to Henry Ford and other
people but also new institutions were
going to arise to give them a place to
actually invests money and one other
thing about the war taught them how to
invest and it may be more important than
we realize and that was the four major
bond drives of the war for the first
time people bought securities prior to
that the only thing people did with
extra money that they knew to do with
was either put it under the mattress or
pay down the mortgage or buy insurance
there really were not a lot of
investments out there and there were not
a lot of people looking for those
investments that changed with the war
and the Bond drives introduced literally
millions of people to securities the man
that you mentioned sunshine Charlie
Mitchell who created the modern
supermarket bank it's a little bank that
you may have known of it was National
City Bank in those days it's now
Citicorp he was the man who first tapped
into this who first understood that you
didn't have to go to the people with
money you could go to thousands and
thousands of people who now had a little
money to invest and together that would
all add up and I'd like to read you one
little thing from sunshine Charlie as he
talks to one of his bond salesman he was
an absolutely great salesman
sunshine Charlie knew how to sell
admirers called him the greatest bond
salesman who ever lived and he expected
his battalions of salesmen to march into
battle with the same enthusiasm he
brought to it Bruce Barton the
celebrated advertising executive recalls
standing with Mitchell at a window in
the bankers Club every now and then
Mitchell mused he brought one of his
salesmen to the club for lunch after
hearing him complained that no new
customers could be found he would then
lead the man to the window and tell him
to gaze at the street below there are
six million people with incomes that
aggregate thousands of millions of
dollars Mitchell would say they are just
waiting for someone to come and tell
them what to do with their savings take
a good look eat a good lunch
and then go down and tell him and they
did and sunshine charlie got which got
rich the the market was primarily in
those early days of the 20s for bonds in
terms of investment it was only in the
mid 20s that had began to shift to
stocks and it was only then that it
began to attract an even wider public
audience The Wall Street were talking
about then is a very different Wall
Street from the one that we're familiar
with now and I'd like to read you just a
couple of brief excerpts to give you an
idea of what that world was like
skipping some material in between Wall
Street was a world apart from the rest
of the city and its denizens were worlds
apart from each other
to outside eyes the streets seemed a
tight narrow community were men expert
in arcane financial skills swam
endlessly and treacherous unpredictable
currents seeking their fortunes by
dubious means those who made their
living there found something very
different a sort of apartheid born less
of money than of class to be sure the
very rich segregated themselves from the
merely rich and the latter from everyone
else but there was as pronounced a caste
system among the very rich as there was
between them and their financial lessers
the first line of demarcation separated
the club from the street the club
consisted of that small band of
investment bankers who dwelled in an
exclusive area topped the leading firms
on Wall Street foremost among them of
course was the house of Morgan which had
held its privileged place for nearly
four decades the towering figure they
called Jupiter JP Morgan who had
transformed himself from a banker into
both a legend and an institution had
died in 1913 leaving the firm in the
hands of his namesake son shy awkward
shambling jack who had cowered in the
corners of Pierpont's life
the second most powerful firm on Wall
Street dwelled in quite another world
Kuhn Loeb actually did as much business
as the house of Morgan or even more and
had its own quote well-cultivated heir
of breathtaking superiority but it could
not hope to compete in the area of
influence and prestige Kuhn Loeb was the
flagship firm of the German Jews in Wall
Street the most successful of whom grew
quite quite as rich as their wasp rivals
but were shunned socially anti-semitism
had been a way of life on Wall Street
since the arrival of the first Jews and
tended to become rampant during panics
when scapegoats were needed the
Magisterial Jacob Schiff had transformed
Kuhn Loeb into a dominant house by
making it the leader in railroad
financing he also managed to develop a
pleasant cooperative working
relationship with the Morgans that
continued after shift's death in 1920
but that pleasant relationship did not
extend to society which systematically
froze the Jews out of its institutions
not all the wasps on Wall Street snubbed
the Jews in their midst but their clubs
hotels and social institutions banned
their presence and few parlors or
parties offered them admittance and then
we go down another layer and I'd like to
give you the other Wall Street which are
the speculators within Wall Street could
be found yet another world one far more
fluid and fickle than the institutions
that gave it presence and solidity the
professional traders who dealt in stocks
were as mixed a lot as the American
population itself but the ranks included
one special breed
the lone wolf whose speculative exploits
gave an otherwise drab financial world
most of its color these operators
dwelled in a twilight realm as insiders
to the market but Outsiders to the most
respectable banks and brokerage houses
they belonged to no firm and enlisted no
other brokers to conduct their
operations
ok Orin I'm sorry they enlisted other
broke
to conduct their operations taking care
always never to let the left hand know
what the right was doing in the sunshine
world of Wall Street they were creatures
of the shadows mystery was always their
ally professional speculators cared
little for anything beyond the forces or
influence that might move the price of a
stock up or down they differed from
bankers or brokers and having no
responsibilities to anyone but
themselves their operations lived or
died by price fluctuations which put a
premium on their ability to manipulate
the movement of prices in the desired
direction and then like wanted more
about that there had always been in the
newspapers
the legendary speculators always what
was new about the 20s was not that the
speculators were more numerous in fact
they may have even been fewer of the
great speculators what was new was the
size of the audience and the kind of
publicity they got because now more and
more people were getting interested in
the stock market and were getting
interested in buying stocks and Wall
Street is a world where being on the
inside counts for everything
particularly in the 20s still true but
particularly in the 20s therefore there
were as one of the great speculators
Jesse Livermore put it three kinds of
people there were suckers there were
experts suckers and then there were
those on the inside the basic difference
between these is that the suckers didn't
know anything the expert suckers knew
just enough to think that they actually
knew something when in fact they were
the ripe as plum you could pluck because
they thought they knew something and so
they were very easy to fool in almost
every speculator went through these
levels before they reached the point
where they actually knew what they were
doing
liber more stories very much that of all
the other speculators in that he went
through he started a very early age he
started with nothing he earned some
money he got very rich he lost it all he
made another fortune
lost it all he made another fortune he
lost it again
hardly ever did they walk away from the
game hole here's just a brief
description of JL as his friends called
him he was born in 1877 the son of a
failed Massachusetts farmer and found
work at 14 as a bored boy in a Boston
brokerage for $6 a week the endless
stream of priced quotations he chalked
on the board soon revealed in him a
remarkable facility for figures he began
to see patterns in their fluctuations
and then to anticipate their movements
intrigued by the game he jotted his
officer Rob survey shion's down in a
little book and became a close student
of the tape until he grew expert at his
behavior while remaining cheerfully
ignorant of the reasons behind the
deviations I didn't ask the tape why
when I was 14 he said later and I don't
ask it today at 40 and that's how he
started he just he had one of these
gifts for mathematics which he
translated and then in a manner very
reminiscent and I effect I make this
comparison of Henry Adams he then has to
undergo his education and his education
light has a lot of parallels to Henry
Adams and it comes out just as badly in
the end even worse for Jesse Livermore
because he was wiped out and I thinks
around 1940 committed suicide but during
that time he had quite a run at it and
it just made huge amounts of money lose
it went back lose it lose it again get
it back and somehow always repaid his
debts that was one one point of Honor he
always insisted on repaying his debts
and in the height of the 20s he was one
of the most at once mysterious and yet
famous of all the speculators anytime
there was a bear movement everybody
assumed that somehow he must be behind
it somewhere and most time of course he
wasn't but
that's the way it was he learned however
particularly in the 20s when the bull
market began and everything was going up
that as he put it I learned the hard way
that there is no right side a bull
market or a bear mark there's only the
right side of the market if the market
is going up you better shift to that
side because if you don't you get wiped
out and he finally learned to do that
but it cost him a couple of fortunes to
learn that lesson as part of his
education and what happened in the 20s
to Americans is on a really
extraordinary thing and this is one of
the reasons why we know so little about
the period we have no way of knowing how
many people actually bought stock how
many people invested in the market but
we do know that a lot of people talked
about it and that in some peculiar way
between 1925 and 1929 the stock market
and Wall Street moved to the center of
the culture had moved to Main Street it
became a topic of conversation among
everybody one of the most interesting
characters in the book I don't have time
to read you a lot of his things but one
of the most interesting characters is
Groucho Marx who along with his brothers
learned about the stock market invested
money made a lot of money when
everything was going up and this is easy
what a racket this is just keep pouring
more money and didn't have a clue what
they were doing and the interesting
thing about it is that although his
brothers were wild men Groucho Marx was
a very financially conservative very
balanced guy and yet he ended up putting
all his money into the market and after
the crash he lost something like two
hundred and forty thousand dollars which
was oh they said I would have lost a lot
more but that was all I had
and it just it it never occurred to them
that the market would go down because it
never had in the time that they knew
about it and they didn't know very much
about it of course and with that begins
many of the parallels to the modern era
which is what interest people in the
1920s it was the new era the 1990s it
was the new economy and they both had
one common element which runs throughout
about three or four episodes in American
history since the crash that one common
element is the belief that somehow the
rules have changed it's a new world
we're not playing by the old rules
things are no longer what they used to
be and therefore the old way of doing
things doesn't apply you can't go by the
old conservative ways of investments and
so you don't have to worry about the
market crashing or going down like it
used to because now we have ways to
prevent that and they really believe
that in the market during nineteen
twenty eight and twenty nine the actual
bull market when when it really took off
it really took off about March of 1928
and it just kept going up not just
straight up it would do what happens
when you get this kind of market which
is a sharp rise a collapse it would come
back a collapse another sharp rise a
collapse and what that did was to Train
these people who were already mouthing
the new irre mantra that well even if it
collapses it'll come back because it
always has and so you could not convince
them to sell their stock and in 1929
when it got so high that it was just
literally had taken leave of reality
although there were some economists then
and later who insisted that wasn't so he
still couldn't get people to sell except
for a select few one of those select few
was Joseph Kennedy
of John F Kennedy John Kennedy had a
couple of experiences the one of which
was with a legendary figure on Wall
Street in the late 20s
a young shoeshine boy named Pat Bologna
who had a lot of the big rollers like
Joe Kennedy and Charlie Mitchell and
others as his clients got good tips
saved his money put his money into
stocks and wasn't above giving his
customers stock tips while he gave him a
shoe shine and he gave a couple to Joe
Kennedy once in 1929 and the story goes
we don't really know if this is
apocryphal or not the story goes that
Kennedy came home and told his wife that
a market that a shoeshine boy can
predict as no market for me to be in and
he whether it's true or not he sold out
and he was one of the few that got out
there were some others who got out but
the interesting thing I'm talking now
about professional people like Bernard
Baruch and others but the interesting
thing about them is when the market
collapsed and it kept going down they
started coming back in because they
assumed at some point it was going to
hit bottom and this was a good time to
buy they did not know what lay in the
future and what lay in the future was
this the crash as we call it really
isn't a one-day event it was a one-week
event and it continued on really until
November November 13th that's when the
market finally started going up again
when the market started going up again
it gained of a good bit of itself back
by the winter of 1930 had gained back
about 2/3 of what it had lost thus all
sound familiar
and people were believing that the
market would finally come back because
the economy would come back but all
during that time from October of 1929 to
march of 1931 thing was on everybody's
mind would the disease spread from the
financial community
to the economy everybody kept saying and
sistine hoping praying that it would not
but in 1930 the economy began to slow
down but the depression is such people
very often forget this the depression
did not start with a crash the
depression did not really start until
about the fall of 1930 and during that
period there was hope that there
wouldn't be a depression that might be
of you know some slow quarters
another thing that sounds familiar right
now we are right now in that phase with
this market what none of those guys who
came back in new was the Great Crash
turned into the Great slide and the
market dropped steadily until mid July
of 1932 and the prices that stocks were
in July of 1932 were unbelievable when
you compare them to what they were in
July of 1929 and the people who kept
along the way buying back in thinking oh
surely we've hit the bottom now we're
still losers so you could have not been
wiped out and you've got you could have
been wiped out later but of course no
one could have predicted that the other
interesting element that bears a
resemblance to the modern market is that
one reason even in 1929 why a number of
people didn't sell their stocks when
they were high at their peak before
October 29 is because they didn't want
to pay the very high capital gains tax
they would have had to pay on the huge
prize not that the capital gains tax was
so high it was that the profits on the
stocks that they had bought were so high
and so they just held on rather than
celled and paid a tax a few months later
they didn't have to worry about that tax
at all there was no problem with a
capital gains tax the market took care
of that so the lesson that we learn from
it was
how can you predict what the market will
do in terms of not just itself but its
effect on the economy and as the past
few months will tell you I hope it will
tell you we haven't a clue we still
don't understand what that relationship
is the one thing that we think is a
connection between the market then the
market before then and the market since
then is that the single most important
element is the psychology of the
investors if they look at the market or
they look at the economy there's a huge
difference between whether they see a
glass half-full or a glass half-empty
and we don't know what makes that shift
go from one vision to the other but once
it goes it's very hard to get back and
that's when the market starts to take on
a downward momentum of its own and at
some point the vision shifts back and it
takes on a momentum in the other
direction but we still don't know how
why and most important of all when so if
you've come for the answers to those
questions I'm sorry to disappoint you
thank you be happy to entertain any
questions you might have young
I'm wondering if you could talk about
some of the things that were put in
place after the crash on the federal
level and the impact that they've had
since then and if they're gonna be I
know you can't say about now for sure
but could you describe that oh yes yeah
Wall Street was changed forever by the
crash and by scandals that came out
after at the crash the Banking Act of
1933 instituted a number of changes up
to that time the New York Stock Exchange
which was the primary exchange was a
completely self-regulating
self-governing institution and nobody
could touch what it did and it could be
as arbitrary about its among its
activities as it wanted to be after the
Banking Act the SEC was created to
oversee the stock exchange it never
again was a self-governing institution a
second change that took place was that
the Banking Act separated commercial
banking from Investment Banking
investment bankers are people who deal
very little with the public they don't
deal at all with the public actually
they deal only with large companies very
wealthy individuals people who do
investments and they underwrite security
issues primarily commercial banking
perform all of the range of what you
might call retail banking operations and
they can underwrite securities and they
can do some other things but but they
really inhabit a different world
basically any and all banks could do
both of those things the banking act
said choose one and to give you an idea
of what happened when they happened when
that went into effect the house of
Morgan that I mentioned is the dominant
house had to split itself and the house
of Morgan remained as the investment
banker and then it had to spin off a
second company which became Morgan's
and the two companies worked hand in
hand for many years but in the
post-world War two ERA no more and so
the house of Morgan became an entirely
different entity that's true of almost
all the major firms now one of the
interesting things that happened in the
years leading up to the recent market
collapse there was talk of repealing
this and I'm not sure how far I got
there was I know there was actual
legislation but I can't remember if it
passed or not and the idea was that
allowing banks to do both again it
didn't work very well then a third thing
that happened of course was the currency
was regulated and in a way because we
went off the gold standard
not with a banking act but with a later
act the Thomas Amendment and by going
off the gold standard the government
basically took over the regulation of
the gold supply and of the currency and
that had a profound effect in I don't
have time to explain the ways in the
house but these are just the tip of the
iceberg but by putting the federal
government into this regulatory position
Wall Street now had to conduct its
business in a different way than it had
ever had to conduct it before and the
characters who worked Wall Street had to
do things in a different way
and they learned to do that as we know
yes sir
you had mentioned the role played by
investor psychology and economic
downturns and it seems that in the
present age that the greater awareness
of this has resulted almost in a battle
for investor psychology on the part of
political and economic leaders and I'm
wondering if you could contrast that
behavior with the kind of public
response by political leaders in the
1929 crash and depression on a smaller
scale and without television of course
it was exactly the same the image for
example of Herbert Hoover as a
do-nothing president is is grossly
unfair and misleading Hoover within
weeks of the crash started out calling a
series of meetings bringing people
together because he wanted to make sure
that the crash and the financial
collapse didn't spread to the economy he
literally did more within the next five
months then virtually any president had
ever done in terms of intervening in the
economy because remember in those days
the way things worked was if the economy
turns sad that's sad but that's the
private sectors business Grover
Cleveland put it in a nutshell during
the depression he presided over he said
it is the duty of the people to support
the government it is not the duty of the
government to support the people and is
not the duty of the government to go out
and regulate the economy
well Hoover didn't believe that he
didn't believe that Washington should
regulate but he believed that it should
take a leadership role so there is in
the months of November December January
February March all the way up to the
spring of 1930 a really intensive
campaign that you might call a sunshine
campaign that everybody is trying to
convince everyone else that the economy
is sound that the the slide has been
stopped it will not affect the economy
businessmen pledge not to lay off people
production figures didn't slide down
real fast right away and one reason they
didn't is because the first half in 1929
it's
all kinds of production records so it
was hard to find a bass for comparison
you could look at it and say well yeah
it's going down but it's going down from
a record highs so where is it what we
don't know and this is to me the
fascinating thing is that when all of
these people are saying we believe in
the economy we believe in America we
believe in the future and all of that do
they really mean it or are they
whistling as they walk past the
graveyard are they trying to convince
themselves as much let me read you a
wonderful thing from advertising firm
which illustrates that point it's one of
my favorite things that I found - this
this is from a firm called urban Waze
Ian's company let us let's not forget
that millions upon millions of regular
folks throughout this grand greatly
desiring gorgeously spending America
need power heat light food
transportation recreation and adornment
same as always
they'll go on dreaming and earning and
buying in those in that lavish fashion
that has always characterized the
shortest memory and longest confidence
people that ever lived
well it didn't quite work out that way
and one thing is for sure no one ever
expected 10 years of depression let
alone depression It was as if a giant
engine had ground to a halt and no one
knew how to start it again which is why
we're very uneasy when we start seeing
symptoms of its slowing down and
starting to grind to a halt because we
still don't really know how to start it
again although we think we know more
than we did then yes sir
took a lot of government spending
starting it again well I'll put it the
other way around the government spending
didn't really start it again the New
Deal never fixed the depression the war
the war yes oh yes
government spending could could be
rather than be a reaction in a war it
could just be a planned event government
spending could correct the market or
couldn't it well it depends because the
spending in the case of World War two is
rather colossal and it galvanized and
organized the entire economy one of the
really strange things in American
history is it you have this generation
of people who went through the
depression they've had ten really hard
years and for some of them longer than
ten years and then suddenly you go from
a situation where you can't find a job
to one where there are more jobs and
there are people to fill them railroads
who have car sitting everywhere going
unused now suddenly can't find enough
cars to haul all the stuff that's being
and this complete flip-flop from
depression to full employment and full
production plus was just an amazing
thing just one one really intriguing
thing I think it's one of the most
frightening things because it only
enhances the uncertainty how do you
figure 1987 into your thinking of all of
the history of rises and falls and the
fact that that did not have tremendous
economic consequences in terms of
creating a
a depressant I mean perhaps a recession
but in the in the 90s but certainly not
a nothing of the scale of 1929 how does
how do you as a student of this what
what do you make of that well the
economists asked that question a lot my
take on it and this is just my taking in
the book
look let me read you just one paragraph
at the end of the preface which will
tell you where we're going with this or
the introduction it may be that in the
end the best way to understand the crash
and the depression that followed is one
that satisfies neither historians nor
economists both the crash in the
depression can be viewed as aberrations
and their relationship as the product of
an unlikely and unpredictable sequence
of events the random coming together of
a confluence of unfortunate forces the
accumulated effect of these forces not
only created the crisis but prolonged
and deepened it much like the
strengthening of a routine storm into a
killer hurricane or blizzard when a
variety of unfavorable factors each one
unpleasant but not lethal in itself
combined on rare occasions to forge the
worst case scenario in short the crash
in its aftermath was the perfect storm
and I think what happened in 1987 was
those other factors didn't converge now
what worries me about the present is
September 11th two-footed Miley is one
of those factors that no one could have
predicted but which has had a
devastating blow and a long-term blow on
the economy how it will work out I I
don't know but if enough of those things
happen I think you get what happened
after 1929 it's you know it's the
blizzard and in 1987 there were a lot of
other things going on that prevented
that from happening
and most people were absolutely
astounded when the market bounced back
as fast as it did because that was a
huge drop but it came right back
indeed it had done that in December of
1928 the market had a huge drop and
everybody were singing people were
singing requiems to the bull market two
weeks later three weeks later after the
market had done this for a while
started up again anything else
well thank you all very much thank you
very much professor Klein will be
signing books right here and I want to
thank you all for coming